hola bienvenidos una vez más a esta
emisión de canadá en las américas café
el programa semanal que ofrece el
servicio en español de radio canadá hoy
estamos aquí en el estudio con una
versión reducida e invernal de nuestro
equipo
esta hora chapman que toda vez que tal a
todos y leonardo gimeno
reducida pero cuán importante es
importante y de una sola nacionalidad
exacta de las américas café mi nombre es
visitamos entonces aquí para ofrecerles
esta nueva emisión correspondiente al
viernes 25 de enero de 2019 como ustedes
saben el programa estará dentro de poco
rato más en el sitio de internet de
radio canadá www.bcn.cat permanecerá
allí durante todo el sábado y todo el
domingo y como ustedes ya saben también
nos pueden seguir en directo a través de
facebook live así que aprovechamos a
saludar a todos quienes estén
siguiéndonos a través
y facebook facebook la eba
y también nos pueden seguir a través de
nuestro sitio en internet en youtube
donde está también la emisión completa
esas son las vías de comunicación que
tenemos variadas más de un canal
entonces para que nos continúen para que
nos sigan como han hecho desde hace ya
tantos años como esta que ustedes o bien
digamos casi no vengo porque cuando yo
dije equipo reducido en real a la
presentación yo la había escrito y yo
nada más porque ayer a tengo que
reconocer que ayer me costó mucho venir
aquí al trabajo la cantidad de agua
lluvia y hielo porque como había nevado
muchísimo durante la semana pasada pues
empezó a hace dos días una lluvia que no
paraba y finalmente me costó salir de la
casa y venir acá por lo lo peligroso es
decir no ya no estoy hablando tanto del
agua en parte sí pero si no del hielo
que estaba abajo del agua y eso es lo
peligroso es un desastre porque aparte
desde mi modesto punto de vista la
limpieza no se realizó como en otros
años
entonces se acumuló que se dejó se
esperó porque hubieron dos tormentas
seguidas aparte no si eso también
complica un poco las cosas que hacer on
25 30 centímetros el lunes y calderón de
nieve de nieve calderón 30 centímetros
más de nieve el miércoles y después yo
ya me duela y después subió la
temperatura y después lo que decían los
meteorólogos dicen que es muy raro que
se den esas tres cosas al mismo tiempo
en un día que fue creo que el domingo o
el lunes
no me acuerdo bien que se dio al mismo
tiempo una cantidad de nieve
impresionante se dio viento muy fuerte
es decir una tempestad porque
normalmente cuando nieva no hace tanto
frío pero hacía muchísimo frío caía
nieve y mucho viento quedaron como 30
centímetros con 22 23 agujeros que
normalmente
exacto y es lo que hizo por ejemplo en
la ciudad de québec s había un artículo
muy interesante donde decía que en los
autos no arrancaban por ejemplo
el lado los alumnos no arrancaban no
entonces para terminar esto ayer me
costó muchísimo venir acá y dije no
puedo poner en riesgo no me quiero
romper nada ya me pasó una vez entonces
ayer previnah y dije no creo que entre
hoy no estoy segura que venga pero
finalmente estoy acá pero me costó
también venir un poco leonardo dice que
las condiciones estaban mejor también
hoy sí sí para mí si el jefe dijo que
hay le costó salir hoy a nuestro jefe
salir donde encontró que había mucho
hielo lo lo lo lo lo peligroso va a
estar también esta noche esta noche va a
ser mucho más frío las temperaturas van
a bajar a 20 grados bajo cero 18 bajo
cero y como todavía hay agua en las
calles sólo congelar ahí sí que bueno
mañana que quedarse tal vez en la casa
tomar un cafecito no y una de las
bellezas de canadá es el hielo negro
digamos es como son las masas de hielo
que están en el piso que son traslúcidos
que no se ven no se detectan un piso y
no es el piso esa capa de hielo arriba
para conducir en autobús no pasa de
largo
con mi vehículo no rápido cerca por la
avenida panamá sección del vehículo eso
fue una descripción de la galaxia y no
hubo forma de controlar el vehículo en
un momento empezó a patinar a patinar y
se me fui contra el vídeo por nada pero
por eso recomiendan muy rápido cuando
hay condiciones climáticas como éstas
que están reinando en los últimos días
exacto ahora ya mí me parece que todos
estos problemas climáticos el
recalentamiento global del planeta en
fin de ser son temas que están tan al al
día en todos lados se discute lo que
está produciendo aquí en canadá me
parece que son inviernos mucho más fríos
y veranos mucho más cálidos
y mucha lluvia yo no sé por qué a mí me
pasa algo extraño voy a decir creo que
estamos de acuerdo lo hemos hablado ya
en una vez anterior en una emisión
anterior el invierno este año empezó
tarde
porque tuvimos buen tiempo está bien
avanzado dice si llegó la navidad y
prácticamente no había nieve pero la
semana de la navidad antes la navidad
que dejó al menos 25
si es verdad y a mí me pasa algo extraño
este año decía que es que en el exterior
cuando salgo a la calle no siento frío
tal vez y por supuesto me abrigo bien no
círculo demasiado por la calle como os
voy a tomar el metro espero el autobús
pero no siento frío siento frío si estoy
en mi casa por ejemplo que no estás
sentado no haciendo nada y con el paso
del tiempo al no tener actividad uno
siente que hace frío pero en la calle no
siento frío entonces a veces
desprevenido y sales mal abriga como sal
y el otro día cuando hacía veintipico 80
y al ratito uno empieza a sentir el
cuerpo del centro es que estuvo haciendo
hasta menos 40 bajos 40 bajo cero desde
esta semana
de aquí en otras partes es de 36
térmicos y hoy acá está haciendo 10 bajo
cero no sé mientras que tienes en las
penas más en el oeste en las provincias
como alberta saskatchewan está 30 bajos
del planeta en australia la semana
pasada tuvieron delgadas altísimas mucho
más altas que lo normal y la gente
estaba como decían esos calcinando será
imposible estar ni siquiera en la playa
o entonces ni siquiera me llama la
atención eso por astrales hace calor y
en canadá hace frío a mí lo que me llama
la atención es la fluctuación en el
mismo día ayer llegué a mi casa a las 9
de la noche y hacían dos grados sobre
cero a las dos de la mañana hacían 18
bajo cero
ya son 20 grados diferencia en un par de
horas y eso es lo que nuestros cambios
muy bruscos lo que sí escuché hoy como
para ponerle otro a otra arista el tema
es escuchar a mucha gente quejarse luego
que dijiste vos al pasar hace un rato
leonardo qué es
no están limpiando como deberían
aparentemente han cambiado donde yo vivo
lo cambiaron cambiará o cambia la
empresa que se dedica a limpiar la nieve
a despejar las calles de nieve y yo
nunca entendí juego cómo es el sistema
de limpieza de la nieve aquí porque se
limpian las calles y se tira la nieve a
los costados limpiando patinando los
autos pero después pasan dos camiones
uno al lado de otro donde uno va
recogiendo la nieve y la batirán en
ciertos lugares en misiones o es el
pasado ya no pasa más en la calle sant
laurent le he visto esta semana
probablemente las arterias importantes
hija sí pero la nieve se queda en los
costados y en la zona que yo vivo por
ejemplo más de estacionar también en
todas las posibilidades
me cuadra entonces la nieve que tira la
topadora se viene hacia la entrada de mi
casa y cuando voy a salir de tu casa
tienes que remover para salir caminando
o para sacar tu auto si tienes que sacar
el auto te la regalo acá tenemos gente
que está empiece a saludarnos muy bien
los lentes
william abril dice me alegro escucharles
indirectos saludos desde cap l en nuevo
bronze week también ha sido una semana
con mucha nieve lluvia y hielo sin
nuevos bronces también la zona marítimas
de canadá
césar rodríguez charlie dice hola hola
hemos estado atentos al clima en quebec
mucho aguante esperar a que cambie
definitivamente pronto el clima dice es
esa muchas gracias
tenemos hasta abril y venta casi dice
buenas tardes acá soportando 45 o menos
45 ardemos no debe ser 40 45 grados
ellas de santiago esenciales
que lindos 45 yo no sé si podría
soportar de nuevo
viví cinco años ha sentido el estero
cuando era niño y a mí me llamó la
atención después entendí el porqué el
canal televisión cerraba la una de la
tarde y volvía a abrir a las 6 porque de
la laguna a las 6 no se podía asomar el
hocico no se podía sacar la cabeza la
cara con la cantidad de calor y ese
calor que uno lo lo golpea el sol es más
alguna vez hicimos la prueba y si
funcionó dejamos una hora en una sartén
afuera pusimos un poquito de aceite se
empezó a coser los huevos muy
probablemente y además en esos horarios
hubiese problemas con los equipos de
refrigeración si tomamos bien sabes en
televisión no se pueden hacer funcionar
los equipos de televisión si no hay un
buen sistema de refrigeración porque se
quema todo exacto exacta así que
probablemente haya sido uno de los el
eventual debe costar también bastante no
es tener ese sistema sí pero más puesto
tener que cambiar los esquemas o tener
que hacer renovaciones de equipamientos
porque se han quemado como ha ocurrido
en más en ocasiones y eso lo aprendí
precisamente trabajando en televisión
pregunta bueno yo a mí no me molestaba
pero otras personas del personal se
quejaban continuamente de la baja
temperatura que había en la redacción y
lo que pasa que la redacción estaba a la
de equipos y el propietario del canal
decía si yo bajo la temperatura se me
queman los equipos así que nos quedamos
sin canal
así que hay que cuidar también en la
propiedad positiva en todo esto
ya se están alargando los días pero como
ya tenemos más de casi media hora
si yo salgo yo me tomo un tren para ir a
mi casa y cuando salgo del túnel del
tren normalmente en esta época está
oscuro y ya está aclarando no es de día
pero eso no es lo mismo que salir de
noche y salir a la tarde y que esté
oscuro
34 ya empiezan a la oscuridad bueno a
quienes nos sigan a través de nuestro
sitio en internet les recuerdo www rcn
punto sea podrán acceder a dos temas
musicales que vamos a incluir en esa
versión de nuestro programa con dos
artistas canadienses ambos de la
provincia de ontario y los dos también
la ciudad de hamilton son dos artistas
poco convencionales
ellos son emilio bonito que es un
guitarrista comenzó a tocar música desde
muy pequeño a los cuatro años comenzó a
tocar piano pero los nueve descubrió la
guitarra y se enamoró de ella y es una
especialista en lo que se llama finger
picking teques es cuando se toca la
guitarra en lugar de rasgar las cuerdas
se golpean con los golpean fácil y bueno
hay muchos artistas que recurren a esa
técnica y parece ser que en medio bonito
es un especialista que tiene un origen
latinoamericano buscando datos
biográficos de él que hablasen
precisamente una libia y no sales en
ningún momento aparece sí que es de
hamilton ontario obviamente era una
aldea local de muy pequeño pero no
nombra nunca la familia evidentemente
con el apellido bonito y el nombre de
milenio gas en hostales sueco no no sabe
el sexo latino debe ver en la familia
es decir otro artista que vamos a
escuchar es el max del el ser que
también es de hamilton como les decía es
un artista que hace una música bastante
poco convencional que mezcla diversos
estilos entre ellos el pop psicodélico
el folk progresivo y lo que llama soul
de ojos azules
es un extra que nunca lo había escuchado
es un estilo sueco azules y además sí y
además es partícipe de la tendencia de
él y esto lo decía por supuesto la
página en inglés de y latina y dijo
vidriosos
hazlo tú mismo ok es decir de no es no
dedicarse a consumir música de otros
sino intentar la música a partir de uno
mismo salga lo que salga
así que quienes nos siguen entonces
estos sitios en internet van a tener ahí
esos dos temas musicales para poder
escucharlos
aquí nos difundimos porque como le hemos
dicho ya en más de una ocasión por
problemas de licencias no podemos
pasarlos a través de facebook
volvemos en un solo segundo
[Música]
bueno muy bien entonces vamos a
desarrollar otros temas que no son los
centrales todavía vamos a dejar los
temas centrales de nuestra emisión hacia
el final como hacemos habitualmente y
vamos a dedicarnos a otros temas que nos
han llamado la atención me decía yo no
ahora tienes un tema ligado a la
inmigración y en efecto a mí me llamó la
atención porque es un plan nuevo es un
proyecto piloto que fue justamente
noticia ayer aquí en canadá el ministro
de inmigración de canadá reveló este
plan cuyo objetivo está dirigido a traer
inmigrantes pero esta vez es bien
específico a zonas remotas de canadá
rurales y del norte donde la gente no
necesariamente se entusiasma para ir es
son zonas como por ejemplo el norte de
ontario lejano norte de bien más al
norte donde al igual claro donde hace
más frío por esas zonas remotas porque
se está como vaciando hay pueblitos que
se están quedando vacíos en el norte
norte por ejemplo de ontario hubo una
reunión el año pasado de los
desde esas zonas ciudades de ontario
preocupados por la la gente por la
emigración hacia las acciones que la
gente por un lado está envejeciendo cada
vez más los canadienses envejecen la
población no se renueva y mucho menos en
esas zonas entonces un inmigrante que
llega a canadá va a vancouver se va
viene a montreal o va a toronto son las
tres grandes ciudades canadienses y
están sobrepobladas probablemente y se
están vaciando estas regiones remotas
entonces es un plan específico que
quiere que está desarrollando y que pone
en marcha canadá a partir del primero de
febrero creo y va a trabajar en
conjunción con las municipalidades y
quieren desarrollar un tipo de
inmigración que favorezca la integración
de los nuevos inmigrantes con planes
sociales de trabajos y que de alguna
manera les permita quedarse integrarse y
no irse a las ciudades porque lo que
está sucediendo es que llegan a esos
lugares y se van a las realidades
por un lado por ejemplo aquí mencionan
el caso de la isla del príncipe eduardo
que es la provincia donde que más
inmigrantes pierden o los no logran
conservarlos y entonces han elaborado un
plan proyecto pilotos o en las cuatro
provincias marítimas de canadá en 2017
el mismo proyecto piloto que ahora lo
extienden a todo el canadá porque parece
que funciona entonces por ejemplo es
decían que una de las hipótesis que
manejan los investigadores de por qué en
la isla del príncipe eduardo no logra
retener a estos inmigrantes es porque
cuando llegan es una población muy
homogénea la de la isla del príncipe
eduardo entonces por ejemplo si llegan
africanos llegan latinoamericanos no hay
comunidades de esas esas personas que
los puedan acoger y entonces la gente un
poco no no se integra como debería y se
van entonces ahora lo hacen de otra
manera entonces está este reportaje está
en radio canadá internacional si la
gente después quiere interesarse un poco
pues ahí lo tienen y es zonas remotas y
es decir estamos hablando de frío pues
son zonas también donde hace frío
pero en el frío se vive y se vive muy
bien también recuerdo lamentablemente no
recuerdo su nombre pero sí recuerdo que
más o menos en la misma época que yo
llegué a canadá llegó también otro
argentino a canadá que se fue a vivir
precisamente a la isla del príncipe
eduardo y que en un intercambio de
mensajes de correspondencia que tuvimos
en los primeros tiempos después de perdí
la pista él me decía que estaba
enamorado de la isla del príncipe
eduardo
y si mal no recuerdo que era artista
plástico o fotógrafos en que estaba como
en su salsa de claros pero otras
personas cuando no encuentran las
facilidades de empleo y de inserción
cultural que exactamente deberían
encontrar para poder este juego es
justamente esa integración se va es que
es natural también no favorecer la
inmigración en las regiones es algo que
se habla aquí desde hace mucho tiempo yo
de hecho cuando llegué llegué a una
región aunque por cierto no era menos
llegué a latino que es una ciudad que
está dentro de la provincia de québec
pero enfrente de ottawa
están en la frontera cuando estamos acá
en una frontera de hecho se puede cruzar
el puente
tranquilamente ya saben muy pocos
minutos y está uno en ottawa en la
capital nacional que pasaba en gatineau
bellísimo paisaje un parque de los
parques más grandes y más importantes de
canadá que es el parque de la cantina
etcétera etcétera pero oportunidad
laboral
pero claro claro no ahora este plan
justamente y por eso está elaborado de
esta manera contempla el empress y
aparte yo creo que también tiene que ver
con la cuestión social yo lo que veo es
la gente que proviene de países árabes
se junta con gente de países árabes y la
gente que viene y de tu mismo lugar
cargues eso te ayuda también a la
integración en él y si no hay gente de
esas nacionalidades o esos orígenes es
difícil también sentirse como en casa
exacto ahora hay gente valiente en todas
partes del mundo y yo me acuerdo uno de
estos viajes que hicimos al territorio
de yukon donde hicimos reportajes
especiales fuimos al encuentro de los
latinoamericanos que viven en el yukón y
sorpresa había muchos y de brasil que
sabemos brasil es un país tan cálido
caliente de no había brasileños había
mexicanos había un restaurante mexicano
eso no me olvido en medio del yukón &
aquí tengo comentarios antes de pasar a
otras cosas
gustavo o lucas dice desde melo en
uruguay recién escuché a leonardo junto
con stefan parada en el programa en
francés aprovechó escucharlos a ustedes
a partir de marzo a la hora del programa
en vivo debo ir a clases así que estás
aprovechando para escucharnos
un saludo grande a gustavo juan carlos
miranda duarte saludos a todos y
mientras ahí tienen frío acá calor dice
y gustavo lucas vuelve con otro mensaje
dice uno de los lugares donde trabajó
como docente es en la prisión de mi
ciudad les comento que por las mañanas
veo el informativo de radio canadá con
selling ali pointer 5 y dice que
novedoso en francés escuchando el
programa y no sé dónde donde trabaje es
de uruguay pero el lugar donde trabaja
como docente tiene acceso a tvc
pero además decimos porque te interesas
tanto en francés y no entiendes
antes interesantes y muy bien muy
delante de pasar al siguiente tema que
quería comentar vos leonardo los invito
a leer alguno de los mensajes que nos
han hecho llegar por éxito
exclusivamente así que yo no requieres
leer alguno voz bueno acá tengo dos del
mismo tema que se bueno uno desde el
tele en el ejército de canadá levantaría
requisito de ciudadanía para aumentar
sus efectivos porque antes para entrar
en la real policía montada de canadá
pues tenías que ser ciudadano es que
escribe luis fernando ávila quien desde
colombianos dice que es capitán del
ejército trabajó 15 años en esa
institución
hace dos años y quisiera formar parte
del ejército canadiense está muy
interesado eso es el comentario que nos
deja él después dice otro tema tenemos
acá solo paralelo otro es cuando nieva
los globos modifican su comportamiento
escribe jota héctor y dice consideró que
el encabezado está mal escrito
cuando nieva dice sería cuando nueva
discusión de venezolano yo conozco y hay
gente en ciertos localidades de colombia
que dicen cuando nieva en vez de nirvana
vez que escucho yo lo discutiré nos
expresa una eventualidad se expresa
mediante el uso del subjuntivo y la
subjuntivo en este caso es correcto pero
igual cada vez que escucho pero digo
bueno es un verbo irregular también el
verbo es nevar entonces nieva no sería
ni llorar pero está correctamente
escrito bueno se toma que un mensaje que
nos envía hilda marval sobre el tema una
grieta en la antártida inquieta los
científicos y dice tienen razón es en
parte es culpa del calentamiento global
pero qué me dicen de las perforaciones
que hacen los científicos
estadounidenses en el hielo antártico no
generan calor esos equipos y fracturas
de hielo bueno si nos ponemos a la
pregunta vale justamente hablábamos
también en el parma en francés de la
cuestión de
la contaminación y una búsqueda en
google pone en funcionamiento no sé
cuántos cientos de servidores y eso
genera calor también volar o sea generar
calor y aquí tengo un mensaje de 7 horas
será cada vez más rápido obtener la
residencia canadiense y douglas celedón
chavarría nos dice soy nicaragüense y
estoy con mi hija de 17 meses de edad
desde hace tres meses y medio en canadá
ambos tenemos el estatus de refugiado y
tenemos todos los beneficios que canadá
y toronto nos ofrecen nuestras
situaciones emocionalmente dura
emocionalmente dura ya que nicaragua
quedó mi esposa y mi otro hijo de cuatro
años esposa madre de ambos niños
quisiera saber como puedo hacer para
pedirlos lo más rápido posible ya que mi
estatus es por ser perseguido por el
gobierno corrupto y sus fuerzas
paramilitares en nicaragua dios los
bendiga y bueno en este caso douglas no
tenemos la información pero me extraña
que siendo integrantes del mismo grupo
familiar no estén incluidos en la en el
grupo un grupo yo
refugio la esposa y el otro hijo así un
otro hijo de cuatro años
no lo pasa es que probablemente el de lo
como líder pues reunificación familiar
mientras son refugiados no sé si
funciona de la misma manera debe ver
algún álbum vacío legal en el caso de la
concesión de refugio cuando uno de los
miembros de un matrimonio está siendo
amenazado el refugio se otorga el grupo
familiar
a las personas y eso también lo hicieron
para una nota tengo acá un comentario de
lo que estábamos hablando del plan de
canadá para atraer inmigrantes a zonas
remotas del país y escribe de maris
damaris arencibia cuidan y dice hola soy
cubana y junto con mi familia vivimos en
chile estamos muy interesados en el
programa piloto del norte de canadá por
favor si pudieran poner los formularios
les agradecería muchísimo bueno antes
que nada nosotros somos
una radio no somos una agencia de
inmigración nosotros damos la
información que el gobierno canadiense
en este caso que fue difundida ayer pero
si vas a hacer al ministerio a la página
de inmigración canadá y que hay partes
que están en español también creo que
ahí están todos los formularios bueno yo
tengo un tema que nos envió un mensaje
perdón que nos envía jose no tengo el
apellido y sigue sobre el tema abundan
ofertas de empleo en la industria
canadiense de la marihuana y él nos dice
buenas tardes soy venezolano me interesa
la oferta de trabajo como sería el
proceso para ir a trabajar nunca he ido
a canadá y es verdad a la actividad de
la venta la industria de la venta de
productos en base a la marihuana está
generando expectativas en un hacerlo es
siendo está creciendo está originando
inversiones lo que parece ser que no
están dando del todo bien todavía es el
suministro porque algunos los locales
que se vivan sábado 27 10 a semana
todavía siguen atendiendo durante cuatro
días realmente no llegan y algunos que
se iban a abrir si el resuelto no
abrirlos
así que la expansión del mercado viene
un poco más lento de lo que se había
previsto tienes otro mensaje tengo otro
mensaje canadá de su plan de inmigración
2018 ya jordan correa dice soy cubana y
estoy en rusia con propósito de emigrar
a canadá necesitas agradece soy un
candidato para las nuevas leyes de
inmigración en canadá estoy con mi
familia tengo dos niños en mi esposa
estamos casados y tengo también a mi
suegra soy plomo de oficio y tengo
licencia que avala este oficio así que
hayan jordan correa le decimos lo mismo
el sitio de inmigración canadá tiene
todos los datos para saber si la
aplicación sería un aceptada y si uno
puede o no conviene hacer la aplicación
para venir a vivir la canaco no se
inicia una aplicación en el sitio de
internet que ya da la información básica
y de ser y de ser viable el trámite
luego esto pasa a la embajada del país
en el lugar en el que se encuentra el
postulante y a partir de allí iniciar el
proceso de manera más puntual pero es a
través de los organismos oficiales que
deben
iniciar intentar cualquier proceso y por
supuesto informarse detalladamente sobre
el caso teníamos otro tema que quería
comentar
dos mensajes y después el tema
dice en él son en contra el rincón que
según buenos días dice buenas tardes
desde barranquilla colombia y gustavo
lucas nos comentan y se estudia francés
en alianza francesa obtuvo el diploma de
traductor comercial de francés español y
en la actualidad trabajó como docente de
italiano en la presión en la prisión que
les conté además de las escuelas
secundarias de mi ciudad
el informativo no lo veo en mi trabajo
sino en casa mientras desayuno y le
decimos a gustavo que si no lo puede ver
en vivo igual tiene él
tiene youtube donde puede ver también
transmisión en la misión en francés así
que el material pero además a que venga
solo aqueveque en radio canadá tiene
toda la información en francés lo siento
tv
muchísimo radio canadá punto sea fíjate
un poco y vas a ver
encontrar muchísimo usted tu punto te dé
también tienes series de que somos
exacto
si no me acuerdo cuál era el de la nueva
guía de la alimentación y eso me llamó
la atención porque vamos para abajo los
carnívoros porque la porción de carne
viene en realmente reducida o sea eso
obviamente es una guía
acá va desde expreso es el fruto del
trabajo de científicos y nutricionistas
canadienses les llevo años los cinco o
seis años elaborar esa guía no en el
programa en francés se habló con un sí
es verdad si se habló con un
especialista en nutrición especialista
en cuestiones que tienen que ver y él
decía que en la guía canadienses para
privilegiados porque es muy caro
mantener esa guía canadiense y como la
guía canadiense recomienda comer menos
carne con más leguminosas y más frutas
los precios de las leguminosas y de las
frutas pisón a subir la carne tiende a
bajar y entonces además la carne baja
porque hay menor la demanda hablar
exacto exacto menor demanda entonces
muy caras en invierno acá porque las
traen esas las importa si es la grieta
entre lo que uno puede comprar y lo que
recomienda la guía canadiense es mucho
más grande entonces para poder respetar
o guiarse con la guía canadiense de la
alimentación uno debería ser un
privilegiado y ganar un tener
hay que decir de todas maneras la carne
sigue siendo cara para mí a mí me ves
cara y las leguminosas siguen siendo
baratas uno puede comprar en
deportivamente
suelto resuelto
todo tipo de leguminosas y son muy
nutritivas y pues se tienen elementos
que no encuentras en otro tipo de
alimentos y a mí me parece que sigue
siendo para las leguminosas son baratas
también o no así las frutas y lo que me
llamó la atención en esta nueva guía
que surgirá disminuir el consumo de
productos lácteos totalmente totalmente
eso me llamó muchísimo éxito y los
productores de quebec
ya salieron a protestar porque porque
antes la guía te recomendaba tantas
porciones de yogur de leche de queso y
todo eso pasó casi desapercibido eso
ahora no los primeros o los que pensé
cuando escuché la información porque es
decir es decir venía ya golpeado por el
tema de la renegociación del comercio en
américa del norte que los amenaza a
ellos con quitarles una buena parte del
mercado a través de la llegada de
productos importados desde estados
unidos básicamente eso ya había sido un
primer golpe duro para los productores
de productos lácteos o de la industria
láctea
productos lácteos y otra cosa entonces
la industria se está poniendo y lo que
si los animales deben estar contentos y
si supongo será festejar y a mí otra
cosa que me llamó la atención muy
rapidito porque ya nos empezamos a
quedar cortos de tiempo es que
no sé exactamente la guía o la persona
que estaba comentando la información del
otro día decía que una de las
sugerencias es cocinar más es decir
cocinar más para que te quede para
cocinar más en la cocina o muy poco o
directamente si compra comida
de dudosa calidad algunos que ahora
volviendo un poco lo que decía a
leonardo el invitado que tuvieron hoy en
la sección francesa las verduras también
se están volviendo muy muy caras me
imagino las también se refería a eso
porque también hay que importar las
exacto el gasto y la contaminación que
genera todo eso está un coliflor un
coliflor hoy está costando siete dólares
si el pimiento rojo juega es carísimo
hay que comprar con los productores con
los pequeños son precisamente los
víveres de esos viernes hoy tengo que ir
a buscar mi ración de
a la asociación de productores de quebec
y una canasta que me dan cada dos
semanas con un montón de productos me
salen apenas 23 dólares pues baratísimo
y con productos de muy buena calidad y
con un sabor y un aroma que no tienen
sólo por ahora pues locales a productos
locales una pequeña pausa una de más
sexo
sexual
si tú
[Música]
bueno muy bien entonces ahora vamos a
comentarles cuáles son algunos de los
temas en los que ha estado trabajando la
sección van a ser menos temas que de
habitual y que habitualmente porque como
dijimos al comienzo de este programa
somos menos los que estamos hoy aquí
pero como hacemos habitualmente te
sugerimos dentro de todo el material que
ha sido producido a lo largo de la
semana un tema con el que ustedes puedan
abrir la consulta a la lectura a la vida
a nuestro sitio en internet y a todo el
contenido que allí pueden encontrar
quién quiere arrancar leonora
leonardo mañana la historia es pues que
según una organización de las naciones
unidas la inteligencia artificial puede
ayudar a alcanzar objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible y esto es porque
tiene mala publicidad la inteligencia
artificial en realidad hace un par de
años comenzó como que era la revolución
de la especie
se tendría un año y medio dos empezó con
que nos va a robar el trabajo cambiarle
esa persona quién es el culpable de esa
visión que se tiene sobre la
inteligencia artificial los propios
promotores de inteligencia artificial
evidentemente y no me hubieran promovido
su valor para cumplir con determinadas
tareas dentro de la cadena de trabajo
que hoy por hoy son tareas cumplidas por
las personas ese acto bueno y en
realidad la onu no dice que no va a
haber un cambio evidentemente va a haber
un cambio en cuestiones muy puntuales y
va a haber profesiones que obviamente va
a ser mucho más fácil de utilizar
inteligencia artificial que otro tipo de
mano de obra entrar en todo caso pero lo
que dice
esta institución es que los casos sufran
de ejemplos a tener en cuenta y que en
consecuencia deberían ser ampliados dice
y lleva llevaría un trabajo muy grande
de parte de los gobiernos y de parte de
las empresas que están propulsando que
están desarrollando inteligencia
artificial pero por ejemplo en
cuestiones que tienen que ver con la
salud
es increíble
la inteligencia cada vez finita y decía
por ejemplo la detección de objetos
impulsada por inteligencia artificial
puede ayudar por ejemplo la duda la
situación de más de 250 millones de
personas en el mundo que tienen
discapacidad visual claro o sea y
existen ejemplos por ejemplo microsoft
tiene una internet en teléfonos
inteligentes con reconocimiento de
objetos y personas para la gente que
tiene disminución visual
el instituto ma 15 del global institute
ma 15 dice que fueron recopiladas más de
160 casos de usos reales o potenciales
de inteligencia artificial para el
beneficio no comercial de la sociedad y
esto es lo que hace hincapié este este
estudio donde bueno desmitifica y desde
monista la historia de la inteligencia
artificial en lo que nos toca nosotros
vivir que es empezar a convivir con este
tipo de inteligencia además cada avance
tecnológico a lo largo de la historia ha
sido demonizado en una primera etapa
siempre
bueno la revolución industrial acordar
la propuesta más simple es que en fin
cosas que no se escapan creo que a
ninguno de nosotros través de un algo es
incluso más un poco más joven de ello
pero
tienes que recordar el tema de la
llegada de la televisión como se decía
que la televisión iba a terminar con la
radio y fue hasta lo contrario todos
recordamos la llegada de internet
voy a terminar con el libro por ejemplo
y hoy en día internet uno de los usos
más frecuentes que es la electridad es
precisamente para leer textos que se
consiguen de manera digital de verdad no
es cierto no es el no es el libro en la
mano pero son los mismos textos y la
gente lee muchísimo en los medios de
transporte al aire libre etcétera así
que la demonización es casi parte forma
parte del proceso de las tecnologías es
activamente bueno yo tengo si yo destaco
un tema justamente hablando de estos
aparatos de estas nuevas tecnologías que
se utilizan muchísimo también en el
análisis investigaciones sobre el
cerebro etcétera etcétera hay una nueva
investigación que se llevó a cabo acá en
canadá por la universidad waterloo
en la cual los científicos se
propusieron como objetivo ver que era
más efectivo para desarrollar o
conservar la memoria es decir dibujar
algo o escribir algo entonces dividieron
grupos aquí en canadá hicieron les
presentaron en una pantalla palabras
sólo palabras sustantivos y le dijeron
escriban lo que se acuerden y después
dibujen lo que se acuerden no de las
palabras finalmente después de varios
ensayos y estas pruebas se dieron cuenta
de que ambos grupos gente joven y gente
mayor de 65 años porque estuvieron esos
dos niveles etarios tenían la misma
capacidad de recordar cuando dibujaban
esos las palabras que les mostraban que
cuando las escribían los jóvenes por
supuesto había una diferencia recordaban
mucho más las palabras que las personas
mayores de 65 años algo que no me quedó
en claro el dibujo tenía que estar
ligado esa palabra por ejemplo si te
muestran una demuestra ante texto te
escriben
entonces escribe pero había como 50
palabras entonces no sé en cuántos
segundos y que te acuerdas personas que
dibujaban una porción de pizza se
acordaban mucho más después de esa
palabra que los que habían escrito sí sí
tiene que ver con una cuestión mental yo
me acuerdo que habíamos hecho se acuerda
en los cursos de memoria que se hacían
que vendía el instituto nuevo como
memoria
visita cordón chistes y en ese caso lo
que hacían eran una de las técnicas era
generar una imagen visual y asociarla
con la siguiente palabra con otra imagen
visual en el cerebro la visualización y
esto tiene que ver con esos futuros
visiones son dicen los investigadores de
la universidad de waterloo que cuando
dibujamos utilizamos habilidades no sólo
visuales sino espaciales verbales las
semánticas y motoras
todo eso se conjuga para hacer un dibujo
y eso hace además wen y otro aspecto
interesantísimo de esta investigación es
las implicaciones que tienen la gente de
edad y en la demencia por ejemplo los
que empiezan y dicen por ejemplo los
investigadores
creemos que el dibujo es particularmente
importante para las personas con
demencia porque hacen un mejor uso de
las regiones del cerebro que aún se
conservan por lo que podría ayudar a
tener una mejor memoria a las personas
que experimentan un deterioro cognitivo
y esto porque ellos explican qué
las capacidades de ese procesamiento
visual espacial se dan en un área que
permanece casi intacta durante el
envejecimiento normal entonces cuando
estás dibujando estás activando esa área
por más demencia que tenga su inicio de
demencia
está intacto y eso hace que te acuerdas
entonces implicaciones muy bastante más
allá de lo que ellos mismos se
propusiera te preguntaba por qué la
primera imagen que terminó cuando vi por
primera vez tuvo un artículo fue la de
los niños en las escuelas que son
castigados porque mientras el maestro
habla yo estaba haciendo dibujitos en el
cuaderno hay que dejarlos dejar que
dibuje yo me pregunto si no es que sí
porque están haciendo sus dibujos están
memorizando algo bueno así que no los
castiguen a los chicos también eso puede
ser un mecanismo partida entonces o para
mejorar la memoria lógica para acordes
escuchar si bueno no tenemos mucho más
tiempo así que los invito a leer
solamente un pequeño mensaje más de
nuestros oyentes a cada uno de ustedes
si es que tienen silla
y bueno vamos con este la situación de
venezuela divide a la comunidad
internacional esta es una una noticia
que la sacamos ayer donde justamente
ante lo que está viviendo venezuela es
gravemente se puede decir una situación
política muy grave la comunidad
internacional están con o a favor o
contra el presidente maduro en este caso
tienes un bloque de eeuu y canadá y
otros países de américa latina algunos
de europa y por el otro lado tienes a
los gigantes china rusia turquía también
y otros países méxico en la región que
se oponen a toda intervención militar
igual que destino internacional ha
cambiado y ya no se definió de la misma
manera
en realidad antes de leer un mensaje
escrito leo la gente que está con
nosotros en nuestra misión
carlos y dice gracias por la información
porque me pedía el link de inmigración
canadá y yo puse inmigración canadá en
google y mensaje directamente el link
así que se lo mandé por nuestras redes
sociales
javier gonzález nunca nadie señora
méxico
saludos desde guadalajara espero el mal
tiempo no les perjudique en sus labores
muchísimas gracias en maría herrera
dicen y saludos desde san luis argentina
en un día con temperaturas altísimas un
placer escuchar ayudarlos gracias maría
dice que también estamos tratando temas
muy interesantes bueno no tenemos más
tiempo los dejamos entonces por hoy los
invitamos a reunirse con nosotros
nuevamente en una semana y como ustedes
saben durante todo el show del domingo
tendrán nuestra emisión en nuestro sitio
en internet gracias a todos
[Música]
tenemos todos